and the owner of the house took a sword
and he stood by the by the gate so these
people came to S to kill the Jews said
Mr we have nothing against you Muslim
stay in the side we' like only to get
the Jews there you know what did he tell
them Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping a reward
click the link and donate you can the
Jews and the Christians brother and
sisters have lived in Islamic Empires
under Islamic rule in Islamic countries
for decades it was the Muslims when
salad Al took over Jerusalem that when
he saw the hostility that the Christian
the crusaders had towards the Jews that
some I saw they would throw garbage in
their places of worship and some I saw
that there were no Jews in those in
those holy cities it was Salin that
brought 80 Jewish families or more to
those lands to coexist with the Muslims
we saw that in Spain under you know
Subhan Allah when ferdinan and Isabel uh
commit an actual Massacre which we call
an ethnic cleansing or you know got rid
of the Muslims and the Jews and put them
through tortes that nobody ever did the
video we're going to watch sisters is
another testimony amongst many many many
testimonies even of that Unholy shimoli
the scumbag um as you can know he
himself even in videos have admitted how
much he owes he believes he owes to the
Muslims subh who saved many many people
who were being persecuted the Jewish
people this is another testimony from
this Jewish guy let's watch it for our
in this fat can be
[Music]
denied God forbid wonderful I'll tell a
story of my family my mother was not
married yet she was a child and she told
me that they were all get scared to the
second floor and the owner of the house
took a sword and he stood by the by the
gate so these people came to S to kill
the Jews Mr we have nothing against you
you're Muslim stay in the side we'd like
only to get the Jews there you know what
did he tell them on my dead body you
have to kill me first then you kill the
Jews he didn't have anything to lose he
could have told them go inside kill them
I don't care he you know what he told
them these are my children these are my
children I asked my mother he did he
tell he said that yeah he didn't allow
them he stood with the sword that he
have to kill me first because there's a
tradition by the Muslims if someone is
was your guest the Muslim would give his
life for
you that's was a Jewish life with the
Muslims that's the zst would like to
like to raise says no there was such
thing but this F can be ignored is this
F can be
[Music]
denied God forb wonderful so brothers
and sisters what you heard there was of
this Jewish man who was claiming that
his mother when she was a child uh and
she they were on the run because of you
know uh what was happening in in Europe
towards the Jews and this anti-Semitism
actually is um it comes from the
Crusaders from Christians because if you
look at s anti-Semitism and the hatred
of Jewish people it doesn't come from
Muslims it comes from actually the
Christians because they believe that it
was the Jews that killed their God which
was Jesus so they have this hostility
and hatred towards them since that time
then they have many times and I'm going
to show you guys uh historical evidences
brother and sisters where many times
they came now it shows you that that
Muslim man was ready to put his life on
the line for that family and this is
what Islam teaches us uh contrary to the
far and these absolute bigots who are
trying to portray as if if I had a Jew
family in my house that my religion
teaches me to say oh they are you know
we we don't yeah go go ahead and uh kill
them it is the contrary you know why
because the prophet's wife was an ethnic
Jew so Subhan Allah brother and sisters
um to us we know that subh we send we
share so much beliefs with the prophets
and many other things with the people of
the book Subhan Allah so I'm going to
read with you guys what say is just a
couple of examples in history when the
Christians and the Jews lived in Muslim
lands and these are the things they had
to say and I asked this question to all
the bigots Douglas marry to scumbag this
intellectual frud intellectual
Tommy Robinson to all of them have you
guys ever lived under the Islamic
caliphate never you have never lived so
let's go to the people who lived under
Islamic Rule and let's see what they had
to say because you guys have never lived
on Islamic rule so you can't say nothing
about it let's look at those who
genuinely live under those Rule and
let's see what they have to say so this
was a letter sent to uh by Chief Rabbi
of Ed yes his name was his name was
Isaac sarfati okay and this was letter
to persecuted Jews living in Central
Europe this is what he had to say here
in the land of the Turks we have nothing
to complain of we possess great Fortune
much much gold and silver are in our
hands we are not oppressed with heavy
taxes and our Commerce is uh un is free
and unhindered Rich are the fruits of
the earth everything is cheap and every
one of us lives in Peace and Freedom
here the Jew is not compelled to wear a
yellow hat as a badge of Shame as in the
case of Germany where even wealth and
great Fortune are a curse for a Jew
because he he therewith arouses jealousy
among the Christians and they devise all
kinds of slunder against him to Rob him
of his gold Arise My Brothers uh I think
says GTH up your Lions collect your
forces and come to us here you'll be
free of your enemies and and here you
will find rest yes this was a letter
being written let's go to Michael the
Elder the Jacobite patriarch of Antioch
in the 12th century wrote in the favor
of the Muslims here's what you have to
say after condemning the tyranny of the
Christian byzantines who were oppressing
uh certain um denominations okay of
Christianity for where the cities for
where the cities sub submitted to the
Arabs they they assigned to each
denomination the churches which they
found it to be a possession of and at
that time the great churches of amsa and
that of haran had being taken away from
us by the byzantines Subhan Allah it was
taken by their own Christians and the
Muslims gave back to him nevertheless it
was no slight Advantage for us to be
delivered from the cruelty of the Romans
I.E the byzantines their wickedness
their wrath and cruel cruelness against
us and to find ourselves at peace they
are saying that their own Christian
Brethren was oppressing them so much so
the Muslims came and uh uh saved them
Jews Jews felt equally saved in
Jerusalem as confirmed by a ninth
Century Jewish Source uh seph pitron uh
Torah the people who in whose hands the
temple is today namely the Muslims have
made it into a choice listen carefully a
choice excellent and honorable places of
worship they say let us worship the one
God who created the heavens and the
Earth to whom the creatures belong until
the coming of the Messiah and on that
day the true worship will be renowned
and will will be acceptable before God
the 8 in 869 patriarch patriarch the
theodosis of Jerusalem wrote the sarens
the sarens were know as the Muslims show
us great Goodwill they allow us to build
our churches and to observe our own
Customs without hindrance Bernard the
wise a pilgrim monk visited Egypt and
Palestine in the reign of khif M 866 to9
he stated that the Christians and the
pagans are you the Muslims they used to
call the muslim the pagans yeah have
this kind of peace between them that
that if I was to go go on a journey and
on the way my cam or my donkey which
bore my poor luggage was to die or or be
injured and I was to abandon all my
goods without any guardian and go to the
city for another pack of animal when I
came back I would find all my property
uninjured such is the peace now I can
give all more and more brother the
storian John B P Paya in 690 expressed
fascinating sentiments regarding the
reign of muaah he said what that the
peace throughout the world was such that
we have never heard either from our
fathers or from our grandparents or even
that their uh their had ever been like
it in like it now this can go on guys
the point I'm saying is the following
Muslims have never had hostility or
anti-Semitism towards the Jews or even
Christians for that matter they lived
under Islamic rulership paying the jizya
and their lives were protected so much
so the prophet P said AI who lives under
the Islamic rule if anyone was to harm
them they will not smell the frag
fragrance of Paradise The reason I'm sh
the reason I'm sharing this brother and
sisters is to show you guys Subhan Allah
that anybody that dares to come and say
that Muslims have this innate belief in
their religion let me be honest I've
come to Islam for 11 years I have never
ever ever been taught that the
Christians and the Muslims that we have
to hunt them down and no such thing has
ever been taught to me in any of my
teachers in private Gatherings let alone
public they have never been taught to us
so I know it's a big fat lie when these
fake individuals come out and say oh
yeah when I was a child so you know as a
child you you're you're can you imagine
W I have never even heard heard of the
uh capital of punishment of apost
apostates okay so these lies when these
cowards come and say oh yeah when I was
a little child when I was 5 years old
they were teaching me King it's absolute
lies and this man is a witness to that
and the people who are watching this
know this Subhan Allah brother and
sisters so I wanted to share this in
reaction video with you guys of this
Jewish man how his family his mom was
saved brother and sisters by Muslim and
no don't forget in France there is a
specific mosque where Muslims gave fake
identities of um uh the Jews who were
running away from Nazi Germany brother
and sisters gave them fake identities so
they were seen as Muslims so they were
not harmed or killed that's all I want
to say brother sisters may Allah bless
and preserve you guys inah hope you guys
enjoy this video till next
time the prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana T
tells us that our books will be given
and every little atam of Good Deed
you've done will be there and imagine
you see a mountain and you're like what
a lucky person which righteous person
and Allah says this is for you for me
yes what did I do you allowed people to
pray you built a Masid I never had the
money to build a m Allah you helped you
gave towards it and Allah gives you the
reward of as if you built it donate now
guys and do not delay and share the
video for extra Rewards
of